No,
we have some image from physical reality.
We have an interface that is air and glass.
Uh,
what I see here is that there is reflection and there is reflection.
So in case my mother,
everyone understands the term,
uh,
reflection is a least reflect seawall and refraction is right with why Cory
liberal can sure,
thank God discourse is not injured and everyone would cry.
But you guys and girls have it easy because uh,
in Hungary and you would say theme about every dish and fainter ish.
So I think reflection and refraction is much better at that.
At least much more convenient question.
We're just stronger.
Which effect is stronger?
Raise your hand if you think that we a fraction that this is,
this effect is stronger.
This is the question about
in this exactly.
Yes.
So I can see that the refraction has a more pronounced effect as reflection
here.
Okay.
Because we will deal with this in a second.
And uh,
what can we can do is we can actually write up the vectors that we have been
talking about for a case like that.
This is towards the direction of the light source.
There is a surface level.
It looks like this or the normal,
it looks upwards.
This is where it's reflected.
This is where it's transmitted.
We don't have a vector for that and we have the different angles for this.
Uh,
wonderful.
So let's take a look at the simplified version of friend Al's equation.
At a simplified version of finance equation.
This one,
at least it's called slicks approximation.
We have no idea what this,
of what this is about.
This is not so complicated thing.
What this gives me is the probability of reflection.
So hard with Fita is the probability of reflection.
So as I have seen the image,
I am interested in what is the probability of reflection and refraction because
I imagined that the probability of refraction is higher in this case and I would
like to compute it in some way in my computer program.
Well,
let's take a quick look at this are of theater is the probability of reflection.
And this is important to remember because during our calculations,
I will forget this approximately 15 times.
So,
uh,
may I ask her name?
Lisa.
Okay.
Uh,
well if I ask you,
uh,
what is arthy talk,
you will tell me that this is the probability of reflection.
Yes,
exactly.
Because I seriously,
I will,
I be forgetting all the time are zero is the probability of reflection on normal
incident.
So this means that light is coming from,
if it would be coming from the off,
what are the chances that it gets reflected
and
RCO can be given by this expression.
We will be talking about this and one and m two are basically in this is of your
fraction.
Uh,
we will have examples with that too,
but let's quickly go through this and and see if physics make any sense.
Makes listens well.
For an air vacuum medium,
we have,
uh,
let's say the index of refraction of care is one and this animal is the medium
that we go into.
So for instance,
here glass
and
let's see what happens there.
But before we do that,
t is the probability of transmission.
Uh,
obviously if the light is not,
we forget absorption for now.
Uh,
if light is not reflected,
then there is refraction.
It's simple as that.
So if I add up these two probabilities,
I get one.
So let's play with it.
Uh,
are at zero degrees is RCL.
Why?
Because cause sign of fever.
So the cosign of zero degrees is one.
So on the right side I have one minus one.
So the second term is killed by the zero.
Therefore I will have more zero and are at zero degrees.
This is the theater is the decrease the angle of the incoming light zero
degrees.
So it means that it comes from outwards.
What is it?
This is the probability of refraction of normal incidents.
So this is basically the very same thing.
So if it comes like this,
what is the,
what is the probability of it coming back?
Bouncing off of that last,
Eh,
what's up with 90 degrees while 90 degrees,
the cosign of theater is zero.
Therefore,
I will have both of these terms,
very simple and this is going to be one.
So the probability of reflection at 90 degrees is one.
Because imagine that I'm coming from above,
then this means that there is a very likely chance that I'm going to get
through.
So imagine a super crowded bus in the morning and you just cannot fit in there.
How would you like to go in?
And if you,
if you don't care about the,
the health and the intact,
less of the other people,
what you will just running there and you know,
hopefully they will make some space.
I have the best probability if I ran towards them,
if I will be running from the side,
it would be very likely that they would just push me back.
There's a high chance that I will be reflected.
So I want refraction,
I want to get on the bus.
It's so as I raised this and go from normal incidence,
the more probability there is for the rate to bounce back.
So this for now seems to make some yes reflection at night.
The reason look chose the dimension itself.
You have to think in terms of limits.
So what is the probability at 89 degrees?
It's going to get reflected if you just raised that you are going to approach
the problem with the deal for this is a bit of linkedin.
By that we can see that there is like a continuous transition.
Yeah.
From here there's high probably into for your fraction.
As I go to two worst 90 degrees,
there's more probability for reflection and we defined that at 90 degrees.
We say that it is reflection because I am moving along the boundary.
I'm not entering the class by the way.
That's a great question.
I was thinking about this too before.
So let's say that a index of refraction of glasses 1.5 let's compute this thing
quickly.
It's 1.5 over 2.5 squared and I do the very same substitution for the rest of
the equation.
Uh,
but before I get this,
what do I expect from the blood?
That's the another important mathematical principle.
Do this all the time before you compute the result stage,
what you would expect from the result because this gives you a much higher level
of understanding.
What I'm interesting in our,
of what does our of Teton,
excellent.
Okay.
Liza male sit again.
So at the probability of reflection at zero degrees I would say
is something very low.
All right.
Okay.
So I have written this year that are of zero is less than 0.2 up because it's a
probability
is the probability off.
Oh,
so
yeah.
So the problem is your reflection is low.
I would say less than 10%.
So if I come from upwards,
a refraction is likely,
I'm very likely to get on the bus if I ran into the people from the front.
Uh,
okay.
what's up with,
for instance,
uh,
60 degrees.
What we know exactly what happens at 60 degrees because how many degrees do we
have here?
What is the incidence?
Mouth?
It's 60 and we can see that at 60 degrees there is a chance for reflection and
reflection and refraction.
Chance.
Yes.
Higher.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So what I would imagine,
yes,
that at 60 degrees there is a higher chance of reflection.
That is then the previous one I'm in.
But refraction is still stronger as you can see on the image and we,
we are going to compute this and we are going to be lat.
You're going to let nature be our judge whether the calculation is correct or
not.
So 60 degrees,
I quickly uh,
uh converted two radios,
that's more or less one.
And so our of one is all point to this means 20% chance of reflection,
80% of refraction.
It seems to be in line of what I see here.
But this is just my expectation
and what we have been talking about Pi over two this means 90 degree angle.
I would expect it to be one.
So if I converted to radio stuff,
this is 1.7 so our of one point seller pay expecting to the month,
let's put all of these together and let's do what engineers do all the time.
We'll put involved from all thought and try to plot this.
So I imagine that our of zero is less than 0.1 so getting on the bus easily well
are at zero is less than 0.1 so far so good
are at one is less than 1.2 this is the 60 degrees mostly refraction well are at
one is less than awkward too.
So checkmark and are at around 1.7 is indeed around one.
So apparently physicists are small people and physics makes sense.
So pretty good.
But there is something fishy about this.
So this,
this,
this is correct.
I mean what we see here is in line with our expectations,
but there's something fishy about this plot.
Raise your hand if you know what it is.
Okay,
I'll give you a hint.
This plots are of FIFA,
which is,
this is the probability of reflection.
Okay.
What happens after,
I don't know if I would just extrapolate what would happen.
That's not 1.5 but two what would I measure?
I think it would be something like the very least minus.
All right.
It's going upwards,
but it will be at least three.
I don't know about you,
but I don't know problem about probabilities that can be larger than one.
Right?
So this would give me some fishery results if I would substitute something like
that.
Uh,
so let's try to shed some more light on what if I have a vacuum vacuum
interactions.
So below I don't have glass anymore.
I have vacuum.
Well,
a index of refraction off vacuum is long.
So let's just substitute one here.
So this is going to be zero and I'm going to have the second term,
one minus cosign of theater to the fifth.
Why?
Because this is zero and this is one minus zero.
So I will keep this tart.
Okay.
Engineering mode.
What do we expect from this plot?
I have vacuum or air if you wish,
if you will.
And Becky.
Okay.
I started may of life.
What will happen
with
probability of walk,
reflection or refraction?
Raise your hand if you know
there should be the reflection.
Exactly why.
[inaudible]
exactly.
So the definition of vacuum is,
again,
nothing.
There's nothing in there,
there's nothing that could reflect the slide.
This ray of light back.
If there's vacuum with expect rays of light to travel in vacuum indefinitely,
there's no way that it could be reflected.
So since our zero is the probability of that list are a,
sorry,
our data,
what do I think this should be?
If there's only refraction than Desarro,
Thedo will be
fantastic.
Okay,
well let's,
let's plot this.
This looks like one minus because scientists up to the fifth.
This is already efficient,
but that's the globe,
uh,
blah,
blah.
This is what I've been talking about.
So I expected it to be zero.
Uh,
let's plot it.
And this looks like this,
which is,
uh,
not constant.
Zero by any stretch.
So the question is,
what went terribly wrong here?
And it's very easy.
The sleek approximation is an approximation.
It's good for interfaces,
which are vacuum or air and something and not something,
something.
Okay,
so a and B,
it works well,
but it's,
it's a quick approximation because this is the original [inaudible] equation and
this is much more expensive to compute.
And this other one was much bigger,
but it's,
it's a bit limited in use.
So
let's give it a crack.
So,
uh,
what would they say about the vacuum back in interaction?
Well,
uh,
I would substitute Antwan and then two equals one.
This is the index of refraction of vacuum.
Again,
the very same thing back,
just the handle once and then tools are gone.
I'm going to use chicken and metric identity,
which says that the square root of one minus the sinus square something is a per
side.
Okay.
So let's start it to these four.
The consigns got it.
So when I see here is the sign of feet on my just cosign theater.
So what is this expression exactly?
How much is it?
Eight zero.
Exactly.
And this is what I was expecting.
So apparently physicists,
again,
are smart people.